Hello and welcome to this video.
For this video, we are going to be doing the code for the use smart object task.
So what I would like you to do is open up the STT underscore use smart object.
And for this, like the previous task, we have the files it's up mostly already.
We have automatically overridden the end state task here.
And we have two comment boxes so that I know what we're supposed to be putting in.
And in the variables, we have the context so we can easily get hold of it and an input
for the claim hand.
Right.
So the first thing we're going to want to do is check to see the claim handle is valid.
I'm going to drag in the claim handle and get it.
Then the drag off just type is valid.
Again this is giving us a is valid output Boolean pin.
So I am going to hold down the letter B to create a branch and lug that in.
If it's false, we want to finish the task but with a failure.
And on true, we are going to move to that smart object and use it.
In order to move to it, the instruction we need to provide to the AI controller.
So we have in our context here a reference to our AI controller.
So I'm going to grab that.
And then I'm going to show right off and search for move to and use.
And you can see that's going to give us the option to move to and use the smart object
with gameplay behavior.
And that's the one that we want.
So I will now like this in.
Now at this point, what this is going to do is going to tell the AI to walk to wherever
the smart object is.
And once it's got there, it is going to hand over control to the game.
So this is where we fundamentally leave the state trip.
However, we still need a finished task.
So I am going to drive off succeeded.
And then I'm going to search for finished task.
And I'm going to with it selected press control D to duplicate it.
So I'm going to do a failed on both the on fail and the move to fail.
So this is two tasks.
First, it's going to move and then it's going to play the gameplay by the on fail would
be the failure of the game by the and the on move to fail would be that moved.
And the final thing was to do here to make sure we have the input from the flame handle
connected up to the move and control.
So this is where it's going to find the gameplay behavior.
And that is all we need to do.
All of the rest of the work will be done in the game behavior.
And we'll do that in the next video.
That brings us to the end of the quick video.
Next up is going to be a bit of a long one because we are going to need to set up gameplay
behavior.